Condolences, condolences,
condolences, condolences
My sister
They asking for forgiveness
Condolences, condolences,
condolences, condolences
My brother
They asking for forgiveness
We don’t wanna forgive them
We can’t
We must set an example with them
They can’t disturb us, we chasing success
Look at us
They said we should do it ourselves
and we did it.
I have soldiers with me,
they won’t defeat us.
They should just let us be.
We haven't come of our own accord
We've been sent here
They can't ﬁnish us
We haven't come of our own accord
We've been sent here
Our Ancestors are with us
Yes, we turn the heat up for sure
Hey Wena, Hey Wena
Hey Wena, Hey Wena...
Yes, we turn the heat up for sure
Tell them I still have strength
Tell them I’m not scared
The power is mine
I can still go for days being number one
Because they always think it’s a race
when it’s actually a marathon
Tell them I still have strength
Tell them I’m not scared
The power is mine
I can still go for days being number one
Because they always think it’s a race
when it’s actually a marathon
We're touching down and going in
My crew got me
Condolences, condolences,
condolences, condolences
My sister
Condolences, condolences,
condolences, condolences
My brother
No bereavement